it's a reversal of his pledge he made
before becoming president to isolate the
kingdom of saudi arabia we were going to
in fact make them pay the price and make
them in fact the pariah that they are
but now after weeks of speculation the
white house confirms u.s president joe
biden will make a trip next month to
saudi arabia to sit down with its
leaders
officially biden's trip is to improve
u.s saudi relations but the president is
under pressure to convince gulf leaders
to pump more oil to help bring down
spiking u.s gas prices
given saudi arabia's poor human rights
record the president is being criticized
by members of his own democratic party
for ignoring human rights in favor of
economics this is someone who butchered
an american resident
cut him up into pieces in the in the
most terrible and premeditated way
and until saudi arabia makes a radical
change in terms of its human rights
i wouldn't want anything to do with him
the white house admits a meeting between
biden and the saudi crown prince
mohammed bin salman blamed by u.s
intelligence for the murder of
washington post journalist jamal
khashoggi is possible but it's
downplaying the encounter noting biden
will meet with dozens of leaders
including the saudi king salman
president biden is also traveling to
israel and the occupied west bank biden
is under pressure to advocate for a
criminal investigation into the
assassination of al jazeera journalist
shireen abu aklay an american citizen
shot and killed by israel's forces
[Applause]
well on assignment last month in the
occupied west bank city of janine
biden will meet with palestinian leaders
including mahmoud abbas as well as
israel's prime minister naftali bennett
but he's facing criticism
for leaving in place the policies of
predecessor donald trump failing to
condemn israel's illegal settlements or
reopen the u.s consulate in occupied
east jerusalem for palestinians every
single promise that was central to joe
biden's foreign policy as a vision of
sustaining recuperating and reimagining
our role on the world stage has been
betrayed and trodden over officially the
president's trip is about advancing u.s
interests in the middle east
but given joe biden's plunging
popularity the ramifications of the trip
back in the united states may be even
more consequential
kimberly hellcat al jazeera the white
house